hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
well holy [ __ ] May 25th where the [ __ ]
is this year going geez it flies by when
you're sitting there with the mask on in
a closet how are you hey guess what
happened to me everybody you know I know
everybody's going through a tough time
out there you know and as a person in
the public eye I need to I need to make
sure that I'm not tone-deaf
I had one of the greatest things that's
ever happened into my life okay my cell
phone had a broken screen a few you who
saw me on my Instagram live I figured
out how to do that scroll left till it
says live and click on it talking to
Nate Craig whose new special preferred
customer is up on the all things comedy
YouTube page people like oh my god like
you your [ __ ] cell phone EADS
squeegee laughing my ass off everybody
[ __ ] all over me right so I had a
date I had a hot date to get my [ __ ]
cell phone screen fixed well I was out
with my daughter and my wife and we
going for a drive and I had sweatpants
on with shallow pockets thank you adidas
with your sweat pants with these [ __ ]
pockets I don't even think I could get
like I think I know those old school
erasers when you were a kid you know the
big one for the kid with a meaty hands
you know strong of back weak of mine
that big giant or I could maybe get one
of those in there so my cell phone was
in there and when I sat down in that as
I was closing the door like a [ __ ]
alley-oop the [ __ ] you know lob it
and then the dunk it was slid out of my
pocket and as it was hitting the ground
I was shutting the door not any harder
than you normally would but that the
screen was already cracked and that's
all she wrote and it's just when I
touched the screen it looks like a fire
work show it's just all kinds of red and
blues and greens and I keep hearing all
these text messages and of course you
know me I didn't backup any of my
contacts oh I lost everybody's [ __ ]
numbers if anybody who's friends with me
is listening to this please text me no I
did not die of the kovat virus I just
lost all my context and context contacts
and I gotta tell you I haven't had a
cell phone for two days and I gotta tell
ya it's [ __ ] great I love it yeah I
lost a bunch of Pickers sure there's a
bunch of people I don't even know how to
get in touch with but you just not have
that [ __ ] thing on me I feel like I
got out of a bad relationship where we
was like oh wait a minute I used to like
to watch sports why the [ __ ] did I allow
this thing to not let me watch what the
[ __ ] I wanted to watch you know it is
[ __ ] no cellphone [ __ ] rules
haven't said that I got a new one that's
coming in on Thursday but I'm gonna
enjoy these four or five days the great
Andrew thumbless helped me set up so my
I get the texts on my computer so then I
was just really thinking like so then
why do I need a phone the [ __ ] do I need
a phone for every car you get in has
that GPS then granted it's like always
like ten years old you know there's like
squares and triangles you know supposed
to be representing cars and buses and
[ __ ] but it'll get you there it's been
[ __ ] tremendous and I got a whole
bunch of [ __ ] done for like the last
[ __ ] three months I was like you know
what I'm gonna do because I got this you
know I went to a nutritionist and I was
like you know Oh Billy fat again you
know whatever I'm doing is not working
you know and I know it's 90% diet and at
my age is maybe 95.5% day so I was like
give me some [ __ ] meals here it's the
order with which they put them together
and how they all they all complement
each other so I was like you know what I
got these things all printed out
right at some point I'm gonna put these
on these little 3x5 index cards and you
know it was a month's worth of meals so
what's that like seven times four weeks
was four weeks of meal so it's 28 meals
and then I had a buddy back home who's
been [ __ ] you know dealing with weight
issues or whatever sells like I'll make
a copy for you so I wrote him out times
two and you know I got the little boy
coming soon and I just realized like if
I don't get this done before he gets
here this could be like another five
years so I just decided I was gonna put
the [ __ ] thing to bed this weekend I
didn't have a cellphone to [ __ ] and
distract me or whatever and I [ __ ]
knocked it out Jesus Christ you know you
know when you haven't worked out for a
while and you're like you get winded
because you haven't [ __ ] run like
it's been so long since I wrote that
much I think you'd have to go back to
when I was still in school taking notes
that my [ __ ] wrist was killing me you
know like I'd [ __ ] done a bunch of
squats or some [ __ ] so so I completed it
underrated putting [ __ ] to bed put it to
bed what the [ __ ] is it it's hanging
over your head
your wife's [ __ ] looking at you right
she's still banging yeah but she's not
putting the [ __ ] full effort into it
because that [ __ ] thing is hanging
over - yeah it's hanging over your head
it's hanging over your head what do you
need to do you got tuck that [ __ ] in
it's all done I put these [ __ ] things
together three-decade ffice lunch dinner
I had all the day's day well you know
breakfast week one Monday breakfast week
one Tuesday the whole [ __ ] way
color-coded I got the [ __ ] grocery
list for each week in the front of it
missing is a [ __ ] work of art I yeah
so I did that and then there's been no
sports on other than the
paetynn Tiger tom brady phil mickelson
thing which i watched I really enjoyed
that I don't know a lot of people like
bitching about sports but I like no
crowd and being able to hear him talk
and everything like that last UFC when
you could actually I mean it was you
never heard that punches for the most
part they know he said to go let's
listen to that you know and then they
would go back and then he'd hear the
audio but in real [ __ ] time even just
the [ __ ] hits [ __ ] meaning that
a pro fighter can shake him off me I'd
be in [ __ ] traction for the rest of my
life just hearing those sounds it's just
like you know I just sit there and I
watch those guys kick each other in leg
whatever but that last one with no crowd
I was wincing every [ __ ] just like like
the idea whatever whatever the the leg
version of a jab is you know not trying
to be a tough guy over here but I've
been kicked in the shin before and that
that's that's no [ __ ] that's no beach
party is it what's a beach party bill I
don't know I'm [ __ ] pasty as hell I
heard they're fun for people with
pigment speaking of which I gotta give a
shout-out to all going down to the
[ __ ] beach you know goes to the beach
dummies
let's go bees let's go sit in the
[ __ ] dirt and go into some water
where everything and there's faster than
me and can eat me let me go [ __ ] that
dopes dopes go to the beach and they're
a special breed of dope now bug Brandon
a lot of this [ __ ] is I'm jealous that I
can't just run around without with my
shirt off and not get [ __ ] burnt like
a goddamn like I [ __ ] burn like
garlic you got to keep me moving min or
it's gonna be a [ __ ] problem there's
a little jealousy here but I just in
general people who go to the beach okay
you guys thought you guys thought that I
made painters mad at me Lynne I went
today I'm gonna try to see if I can make
people who go to the beach
[ __ ] more angry at me than painters
who phase they've settled out they've
settled down you know they had a couple
of Keystone light you know sat on a
couple of [ __ ] open paint cans you
know that dumb [ __ ] Red Wing boots
with the [ __ ] paint all over him you
like Jackson Pollock except nobody gives
a [ __ ]
you know when you die is somebody gonna
[ __ ] bid on the wall you painted in
that bathroom why do I go after him you
know why because they turned out to be a
really sensitive lot anyway let's let's
get back to the beach [ __ ] the beach
combers it's just it's that dumbs that
dumb dumbs yeah yeah bill there you go
maybe you should be in the [ __ ] beat
you [ __ ] dope huh head in the sand
with your pasty freckled ass sticking up
with the air just the people that go now
there's a dirt bag nests to the beach
dirt bags go to the beach right [ __ ]
scumbags go to the beach losers
live on the beach alright [ __ ] morons
go to the beach and then they have like
this [ __ ] you know this pop
psychology like spirituality man about
the land meeting the water and how like
man you know we came from the water man
right all of that [ __ ] all that hippie
surfer [ __ ] [ __ ] like they're
beating the man cuz they're out there on
a [ __ ] cardboard table [ __ ]
surfing around yeah beaches are for
dopes okay and right now we're in the
middle of a [ __ ] pandemic and at some
point you got to send the GIS walking
towards that atom bomb that just went
off just to see what the [ __ ] gonna
happen and god bless these my breathers
because they're doing it we've been
inside for two months right now and we
need a group of people that we can
afford to lose to walk towards the virus
and see where it's at and go
bless these [ __ ] mouth-breathers you
know they're out there they're listening
to their music tells them about their
country and about their rights and then
you know nobody's gonna tell me not to
get my four-wheeler out go down there
with my [ __ ] Larry Bird shorts up my
ass you know with your dumb snorkel on
top of your [ __ ] head oh I love it I
love it you send the weakest of mind out
to the danger first we can afford to
lose these people we can afford to lose
these people all right so this is what
happens this is did they they're like
the human Groundhog Day right the
groundhog sees his shadow he goes back
in the hole we got another [ __ ] on
her how many [ __ ] weeks of winter
right he doesn't see shadow we can come
out so if these [ __ ] mouth-breathing
boogie-board [ __ ] morons you know who
would down there who listen to the worst
[ __ ] music
right there's no thought it's just like
the most basic pop [ __ ] horseshit you
know you let those [ __ ] go down there
okay and it is it is a win-win either
they don't die and then we can all go
back to smart people can [ __ ] go back
to run and [ __ ] this is the latest this
is so elitist this is just the angry
Rowling's
of a [ __ ] boy in the bubble that's
all all right either they survive and we
can all go back to normal or even better
is a significant portion of them dying
and I'm willing to say that that's
enough to swing an election I'm not
gonna say which way I know both sides
thinks the other side is dumber all
right but we're gonna find out we're
gonna find out okay cuz I have a feeling
a lot of people that [ __ ] vote for
Trump are gonna be very happy okay
because even as dumb is a lot of people
who voted for Trump who can look the
other way at a guy who just told you to
[ __ ] take [ __ ]
a shot of bleach even people that are
that dumb okay this a certain level that
dumb that you get to to that you can't
afford to live near the ocean and you
get pushed into the middle of the
country so what's gonna happen is is
enough [ __ ] mouth breathing morons
it's just a theory are gonna go to these
[ __ ] oceans in predominantly blue
states and then they're gonna come home
and they're gonna start sneezing on
people who don't have pigment and I'm
gonna tell you right now Donny Trump
gets a second term
alright that's what's gonna happen but
along the way we're gonna lose a lot of
dumb people which is is a good thing you
know what a dumb people do they breed
they breed like rabbits okay they can't
figure out how to open a condom they put
it on backwards
you know they're they're morons they
don't plan it out take dick stick in
that go until done that's that's how
they plan their life right they got a
bunch of [ __ ] in their front yard that's
why they go to the beach they don't want
to look at the [ __ ] life they created
so get out there and twerk and boogie
board and [ __ ] roll all over each
other I love it I hope you have a great
time and I'm 50/50 on whether or not you
get sick I don't want you to get sick
because I want people smart people who
have small businesses and actually made
something of their lives you know I mean
what kind of a [ __ ] [ __ ] like the
big thing is it's a [ __ ] beach you
can go to [ __ ] gets gonna be there it's
May Memorial Day I ain't gotta bring my
Oh Bochy down to the beach I love it
there we go that ends my Hollywood
elitist you know pill not everybody has
an above-ground pool if you can't afford
and you're over the age of 50 you got no
one to blame but yourself that's not
true [ __ ] bankers got their [ __ ]
foot on everybody's goddamn neck what a
bunch of dopes out of all the [ __ ]
things out there to [ __ ] about you
can't go to the beach
what about how corporate America is
gonna be taking more of this a bigger
slice of the pie because the little guy
can't survive [ __ ] all that I can't put
them I can't put on my [ __ ] goddamn
Sun Hat and take a metal detector down
there and hope I go find an old iPhone
Jesus you know it'd be great a nice
[ __ ] tsunami I'll just wash them all
away anyway there's a lot of you
probably got upset by that but you do
the same thing don't you think that
you're part of a better group than
you're really in don't you think you're
a little smarter than you are don't you
think that the world would just really
fold for like three days if something
happened to you and [ __ ] up with you
alright so there you go so there's one
for the mouth but I took the heat off
the painters you know what I mean and I
feel bad about the painter so you know
most of them have [ __ ] brain damage
from breathing and all of that [ __ ] and
stripping away the [ __ ] lead paint
and all that stuff you know and they'll
probably call themselves heroes but who
do they have to blame huh who put that
lead paint there to begin with another
painter so you just mad at yourself you
know do you come from a long line of
painters is everybody in your family
good at coloring things in why am I
doing this I don't know all right let's
get back to the podcast here everybody
no advertising this week can you believe
it can you believe what the the
intellect on this podcast that no one
wants to advertise all right you know
what I got into [ __ ] Jeff Porcaro
again Jeff Porcaro is one of those guys
I always felt like his drum was too
sophisticated for my dumb ass I mean I'm
dumb but not dumb enough to go
the beach you know I mean wait till like
need to go to the beach I just left the
beach going down there and eating fried
food and the smell of low tide and
seagulls my dumb plastic floaty toys
what a shark's gonna get their [ __ ]
together I just don't understand it you
know I mean but polluting the air oceans
at what point are they gonna draw a line
in the [ __ ] sand and stop killing
they're [ __ ] you know fish on fish
crime and just start going after the
real pro [ __ ] problem out there you
know just set it aside the way the
Bosnian Serbs did Bosnians and the Serbs
right is that who they were when the
Russians came and then they had a common
enemy well let's take a break on this
and then they fought the Russians for
like a good [ __ ] I don't know how
long 6070 [ __ ] years and then the
Russians left and they were like all
right where were we right that was a
weird time in history everybody had
these weird names like nitin yahoo
Boutros boutros-ghali remember that
whole [ __ ] weird time you know like
is that is that a dictator or a [ __ ]
DJ alright Jeff Porcaro everybody now a
lot of people know him as a drummer from
toto
right played the Purdy bill uh Bernard
Purdie shuffle on Roseanne all about a
team anyway Corinna moaning is grab your
ass Rose they had to change the lyrics I
think right after me too
oh they want to do when I wake up in the
morning as accurate you ask your
permission and getting it in written
form also if I can touch your Derry
general neutral name gender-neutral name
[ __ ] you
anyway I was I don't know what I was
just looking at all these bottom videos
and [ __ ] an old football and stuff like
that and NFL football stuff and I ended
up coming across a couple of Jeff
Porcaro videos and one of them took me
to this album by Robert Palmer that I
didn't even know about like Robert
Palmer
I just knew him is latts our own but
you're not home and those [ __ ] zombie
chicks with no [ __ ] bras on which
everybody flipped out about right now it
was kind of loud I don't see what the
big deal is here they're clearly not
playing those instruments I was a nerd
and I came across this [ __ ] album let
me see if I can find the name I already
forgot the name of it what is the name
of the goddamn album it was his third
album be put out three albums in three
years some people can do what they like
and Robert Palmer had the Little Feat
band backing him and then on at least
one track Jeff Porcaro played on and oh
I know what the [ __ ] video was it was
Jeff Porcaro fills and he was a big
studio drummer just amazing amazing
player and it was just all these these I
mean I thought he was a groove guy I
knew he was a groove guy but I didn't
know he had chops like that this [ __ ]
guy was a beast so that just led me down
this road so I downloaded two albums by
Robert Palmer which sound really
different and I they're from the 70s
like 74 and 75 76 was some people can do
what they like and then I downloaded him
the one that his first one sneakin Sally
through the alley so Bernard Purdie
plays on some of this I believe now this
is all new to me so I might get some of
this wrong he had the Little Feat band
backing him up and was at Richie Hayward
was their great drummer rest in peace
rest in peace Jeff Porcaro
by surpise Robert Palmer I don't use a
lot of dead guys here
what they go to the beach bill geez I
was really blown away but I [ __ ] hate
the sound of drums in the 80s I hate
that whole drum sound it's thinking me
so [ __ ] long to finally actually go
back and listen to a lot of that music
the drums just sounded [ __ ] horrible
I know it was like that the sound back
then and it was new and it sounded cool
but it did not age well for me anyway I
love that [ __ ] from the 70s that dry all
the influences the studio guys back then
the Jeff Porcaro Steve Gadd Richard T
remember that whole band GAD gang or
stuff just those [ __ ] monster monster
monster [ __ ] studio musicians what I
think musicians was I think that whole
thing just [ __ ] went away with the
home studio and all of that I used to
love reading and like Modern Drummer
back in the day they had one album cover
that just had like the the studio
musicians and they would talk about you
know that New York and the LA guys and
there was a couple of guys I think Hal
Blaine literally had like three drunk
giant [ __ ] like ridiculous spinal tap
level drum kits with the concert toms I
think he had no head on the bottom Tom
and he had like two or three of them
just set up like one it like Capital One
I don't know I don't know the names of
the [ __ ] places but he and he would
just just all day long just [ __ ] go
from one to another to another to
another and they did so many of them
that you know they literally forgot what
tracks they played on I imagine if they
listened back they could tell oh that's
me that's something I do or that's my
sound or something or maybe just hearing
the song would bring it back to him but
they used to do these interviews with
these guys and I always thought that was
just such a fascinating way to kind of
live your life almost like the the guy
who gets traded a lot the Chris Gatling
remember that guy in the NBA I saw his
joke about that guy where he might he
played on so many teams I think he had a
head
and he was a bald dude so he was where
they had been I think he had a headband
in every [ __ ] team color probably had
like 30 [ __ ] headbands so he was
ready to go for whenever they were gonna
trade him again he was like with Jersey
Dallas I think he went back to Jersey
like New Jersey and Dallas were like
[ __ ] incestuous for a while the way
they would trade in players back and
forth I just guess the owners just got
along with each other they were like you
don't win a championship
yeah neither do I all right let's just
[ __ ] switch players and make it look
like we're doing something back when
they played in the Continental Airlines
Arena and I was a Trey Union Reunion
Arena and Dallas way back in the day
before the [ __ ] guy there what the
[ __ ] his name Mark Cuban or Cuban came
in
Mark Cuban did one of the coolest
[ __ ] things ever that back in the day
for a million bucks you could buy a
lifetime pass I think it was on American
Airlines and when he became like a
[ __ ] billionaire he did that and if
you had that lifetime pass you didn't
really have to make a reservation he
just showed up like yeah I gave you guys
a million bucks and they'd be like all
right this way mr. Cuban I think he got
one for his dad too
it's like that that right there that's
[ __ ] perfect
you know I guess way you get the private
jet III aren't I think applying
commercial is the way to go I think you
get a better pilot you get a better
plane you're there with a bunch of other
people right I guess that bet part of it
you got to go through security I don't
know I I would just rather be in
something as big as that so if you ever
hit like really bad turbulence you know
you got the weight and the size of that
[ __ ] thing as opposed to being in
like you know those G fives little
[ __ ] missiles flying across that all
who gives a [ __ ] those things never
crash why did I just say that but they
they don't they don't seem to it's
pretty [ __ ] safe what the hell am I
talking about this is like one of these
times where I would just do a [ __ ] I
would do a podcast read and then I give
my brain a break and then I get to
[ __ ] hit reset well not this time
Hey Oh [ __ ] Billy old shoulder I I now
got it up I'm using the pink one-pound
weight I'm up to three sets of ten so my
thing but and then I take an
anti-inflammatory and I sit for 15
minutes three times during the day on
the day that I work and it's been
[ __ ] working like perfect for me so
I'm gonna get myself up where I can do
with the one pound pink wait ladies
three sets of twenty before I then make
the leap the the biggest leap when you
rehab in the [ __ ] is it wrote a cuff
rotator cuff I always forget rotator
rotates right I don't [ __ ] know rotor
I rotors on a car pill I think I don't
[ __ ] know right um going from one
pound of two pots that's the big thing
so when I get up to 20 when I get the
two pounder and increase 100% in weight
and that is like a prince purple all
right when I get to that one I'm just
gonna do three sets of three
inflammatory ice at three times and then
just see where the [ __ ] I'm at and then
if nothing happens then I'm on my way
right because going from two to three
pounds as you guys all know that's only
an increase of would it be a 50% and
then as you go up and then it's an
increase of [ __ ] 25% or whatever the
[ __ ] it is all the way up I don't know I
got to learn how to do percentage just
God knows I have the time I mean bill if
you gotta be the least do you realize
how close I came to be to being on
Hitler's list of chosen white people
I came so [ __ ] close you know I had I
had skin the color of milk I have skin
the color of milk right and I had I
didn't have black or brown hair you know
so like if he was on the game show
and it's like alright Hitler are you
good are you gonna keep the Deutsche
marks you got in your head are you gonna
try to create the perfect race behind
door number one and then the who looks
at the cut they always tell you to go
for it right
so once
take back your Deutsche marks and he
would go and they that thing would open
up and I instead of having the blonde
hair that he thought I would have red
hair and instead of having pure milk
white skin I would have these awful
freckles all over me
and then up a bum way sorry Hitler come
back in 20 minutes you'll get to spin
the wheel maybe you can win a the
showcase I bet the German [ __ ] Price
is Right is amazing your next item up
for bid don't know right what a Porsche
Mercedes Audi you know those cheap [ __ ]
probably give him a Volkswagen they're
not even like a beetle or something it's
probably like the Volkswagen what do
they have now I just movie had the Jetta
the Shalaka Scirocco the rabbit I forget
I did it lied to respect the fact that
they had that whole [ __ ] they sang a
Beach Boys song in German when they were
just like all right we got to make me in
German cool again ok it's the 80s the H
dog was 40 years ago all right
remember that was the GTI they like like
something tiny GT I know you remember
that is that sounds probably more like
me I'm doing a bad agent thing but it
was a German thing they sang it all in
German but it was too like a beach boy
saw Oh Donna Donna not GT Oh like I
think it was a the GTO song and they did
it about the Volkswagen GTI Jesus Christ
how much time have I done this is like
[ __ ] jury duty this week 30 men
he's halfway there did you guys watch
the golf yesterday did you watch the
Gulf it was actually got competitive
there you know everybody was sort of
joking around and then it got like real
everybody just [ __ ] got into it
Peyton Manning Tom Brady you know
what's-his-face Bert Kreischer we did a
bill Bert yesterday and I didn't
understand what he was saying and I now
get it where he was saying that that Tom
Brady and Peyton Manning if you watched
how they play you know this is a
completely different sport and but
they're they're pretty I didn't watch it
close enough but basically how like
Michael Jordan can play basketball at
the level that he does and then also be
like a scratch golfer but like a
professional golfer cannot go out and
[ __ ] become even like a Division one
basketball player for the most part
right but it seems like all of these
[ __ ] pro athletes it's just it's a
different game I don't know why do I
always disrespect golf I don't know you
know if they could just send all the
golfers to the beach no tsunami with
sharks in it am i pitching a [ __ ] I
think I'm pitching a sequel to sharknado
right was there was it was it really a
tornado cuz tornado is like air it
should've been like a waterspout so the
Sharks could still breathe in there
shark spouts does not sound as good as
sharknado not that sharknado sounds good
god I would have loved to pitch that
movie it's a horror movie everybody's
afraid of sharks well you know we've
kind of done the jaws thing they moved
on to killer whales and anacondas and
alligators I just feel like it's been
done wait a minute this also has a
tornado there was a movie about tornado
chasers with Philip Seymour Hoffman
they've already done that no no no
it's that movie meets jaws what are you
talking about I'm talking about taking
the sharks in putting them in a tornado
do these sharks then go on land that's
exactly what they do and it's bad enough
that the tornado knocks over your house
and you like oh my god
has anybody seen Mike Foreman grill in
my toaster that was my favorite
flat-screen TV right [ __ ] it's on top
of your grandmother she can't move right
you [ __ ] try to take the TV off and
then all of a sudden inexplicably in the
middle of Nebraska that goddamn tiger
shark takes your [ __ ] leg off at the
hip and the movie mogul is like goddamn
it can you get someone from 90210 and
then yeah you [ __ ] you [ __ ] kidding
me
I have him attached right and everybody
laughed and what do they make they made
like [ __ ] 16 of those didn't they
they made like three of them how many
[ __ ] sharknadoes with her sharknado
this somebody going around Hollywood
getting hookers and blow being
introduced is he's the sharknado guy oh
did you come up with that shark nado
sharknado 5 sharknado 6 sharknado 7 what
the [ __ ] I'm so far behind
you got a binge watch sharknado how many
sharknadoes dude that is the [ __ ]
best if you're on the other side of your
[ __ ] career and nobody wants to
[ __ ] work with you right and then all
of a sudden you're yeah oh my god what
are you doing sharknado yeah [ __ ]
seven of them you [ __ ] would you like to
see my infinity pool I love a comeback
story alright they made one in 2013 2014
2015 2016 2017 2018
these [ __ ] they're not stop it
this is what kills me is in 2013 to have
one come out in 2014 you're talking [ __ ]
you're like this is gonna be a fun I
don't even need to see this thing come
out and even see how it does we're just
we're immediately moving on to the next
one
like when they shot Back to the Future 2
& 3 back to back right 13 14 15 16 17 18
a Jordan esque run the repeat three-peat
except they didn't take two years off to
[ __ ] do some [ __ ] with crabs they
just did sharks the whole [ __ ] away
the last sharknado alright so let now we
got all right you got to see the names
here we got to see the names this is
[ __ ] great okay
there's sharknado then there's sharknado
2 the second one huh see this is the
thing you guys can laugh at Hollywood
all you want but you just lack the
creativity at the end of the day the
same way I lack the pigment to go to the
beach so what do I do
do I say hey have a good time at the
beach no I wish for their watery deaths
right you guys make fun of Hollywood you
know none of you have the creativity to
stick a great white shark
into a tornado and then have the balls
to take the money you haven't even made
on the first one yet and double down and
come out with sharknado 2 and then on
top of that come up with the killer
sequel name one of the hardest things
ever to do and come up with the second
one right and then they're not done they
don't they like counting cards here then
I go back to the room they're gonna take
this casino down 2050 they come out with
sharknado 3 oh hell no with an
exclamation point huh oh hell no and I
bet the movie started with that with
like we finally stopped that second
tornado with sharks there's no way
there's a third and then all of a sudden
it comes over the horizon with a couple
of truckers in its mouth
and the nine oh two one oh guy what does
he say oh hell no right that's right up
there with we got to get a bigger both
right
sharknado four the fourth awakens right
you think at this point by the time they
made four they'd start talking about it
on the Weather Channel right
sharknado five global swarming people
they made so much [ __ ] money in the
fourth one the first four that they were
now able to take it global it's like a
Will Smith movie you know when whatever
whatever the [ __ ] aliens are they're
attack in Paris they're attack in London
we know all that [ __ ] we know what's
going to happen the American action hero
needs to save the world and even if it's
Jason Statham he's going to do it here
in America right and then the last then
number five number 6 sorry the last
sharknado they have a sense of humor
about their time about their their their
their movie it's called it's about time
named LeBron James name it it's about
damn time cast and crew all right let's
look up the cast here dude irons airing
did all six Tara Reid did all six it's
[ __ ] incredible
Ryan Newman that's not the piano player
is it Aubrey Peeples that's a great name
mark McGrath did two of them I mean
David Hasselhoff did two how him how
have I not watched these let me tell you
that time I did a table read and I guess
I did such a bad job that I didn't even
I did they never asked me back to do the
part that happened a lot to me but one
of the people at the table read was
David Hasselhoff and I got to tell you
something that he was one of the
best-looking human beings I've ever seen
in my life
unbelievable and he was [ __ ]
hilarious
he was David Hasselhoff was so good in
that table read I I was I wasn't even
annoyed that I didn't get the part now
like I wasn't reading the same part I
was reading like you know mr. Herman
paging mr. Herman I had a quick little
[ __ ] thing in there but it was a what
the [ __ ] was that movie I remember it
was really really really funny and
really really well-written and I really
really wanted to get in it and I did not
but I mean I look the way I look so I
always understood it I understood I said
you know when you when you remake
children in the corner and I know I'm in
that one oh that's great just knowing
that iron's earring and Tara Reed right
now is sitting on six movies worth the
[ __ ] sharknado money you know and
that's something to be proud of you know
one of the best [ __ ] lines ever you
know these douches they don't have any
they have no idea how [ __ ] tough this
businesses okay
sitting here with [ __ ] personal
assistants and [ __ ] cappuccino so you
guys you guys couldn't [ __ ] handle
this one of the best lines I ever heard
was [ __ ] Michael Caine when they gave
him [ __ ] for doing he did like jaws 19
or three for some [ __ ] like that and
somebody asked him I guess evidently
this critic thought that the movie was a
piece of [ __ ] and he said hey Michael
have you seen jaws 4 or whatever when he
was in have you seen jaws 3 and he goes
now but I've seen the house that had
booked that it paid for I butchered it
[ __ ] What did he say Oh what did he say
I gotta look it up I got to look it up
he gave him the old right there Fred go
[ __ ] yourself
I did exactly what you would do I don't
want to do that movie how much [ __ ] that
dream house baby Michael Caine Michael
Caine get the bloody head out Michael
Caine jaws quote I've
seen the house this Saudi this oughta
get me it here we go let's see let's see
I haven't seen it but by all accounts
it's terrible however I've seen the
house that it's built and it and it is
terrific that is oh he was in Jaws the
revenge Michael Caine who's an Oscar
winner once said of his role in Jaws the
revenge 1987 that I have never seen it
but by all accounts it's terrible
however I have seen the house that it
built and it is terrific good for him
good for him Michael Caine 50 quotes
about acting huh you want to hear Sir
Michael Caine I always think that's
hilarious when you get [ __ ] knighted
you never have to have a [ __ ] sword
fight all right first of all I choose
the great roles and if none of these
come I choose the meteor oka ones and if
they don't come I choose the ones that
pay the rent I [ __ ] how do you know I
don't need to read another quote I
[ __ ] love this guy all of these years
of people [ __ ] sitting there trying
to [ __ ] act like some piece-of-shit
movie is not a piece-of-shit movie I
mean that's part of being a professional
buddy Jesus [ __ ] address it yeah I
heard it sucked you know I didn't say it
but you know seen the house set of
building it's terrific you can't that
just shuts them down shuts them the [ __ ]
down all right so the running time of
sharknado one two three four five and
six is five hundred and forty minutes
you know they're all on [ __ ] Netflix
oh you know what the [ __ ] you know who's
probably watched all six who I lost his
phone number if he's listening you know
who who could actually break them down
and could rank them
I would guess would be the great an
absolutely [ __ ] hilarious Judah
Friedlander Judah Friedlander one time
we were at the Comedy Cellar and he's
I did ranking what the [ __ ] was his name
how the [ __ ] did it out of [ __ ] that I
just forget his [ __ ] name the guy
with the ponytail made all the action
movies then he became like a deputized
guy and he kept going up to [ __ ]
people they pulled over and she kept
going
where's the gun cuz kept calling
everybody cuz like that was his Street
lingo Stephen not Colbert Steven [ __ ] oh
god this is gonna talk did it look up
one of his foot it's funny I can't
member his name but I can remember
marked for death Steve as a guy Steve as
a Gaul so Judah [ __ ] ranked all of
his movies and then he could
historically put him in what he brought
to martial arts movies and I said to
Michael what was that movie where he
like he was like fighting all those
rastas and he goes marked for death
great movie and I just start laughing I
go what did you like about it he goes
that movie
it's basically he goes Steven Seagal
beats up Jamaica and you know anything
about Jamaicans that's no small [ __ ]
feet those are some of the toughest
[ __ ] people on the planet but he said
Steven Seagal martial art movies
introduced the breaking of bones into
that genre because I remember watching
that and he just kept snapping people's
[ __ ] arms and legs and I had watched
his zillion karate movies it had been a
long time you know it was funny watching
somebody get punched in the face but
when you just saw like the [ __ ] arms
snapping that was like it was like
watching the Joe Theismann [ __ ] leg
break video for like at 90 minutes
anyway let's get let's get to the how
you got to do it you're gonna do it
you're gonna sit there and your [ __ ]
house or apartment you're gonna watch
540 minutes - sure
Nadel I think you got to do it I pinched
watch sharknado just don't do it
ironically huh
actually sit down and just enjoy the
amount of [ __ ] work to put out six
feature films in six years I mean you
just you never you're never not editing
you're never not writing and you're
never not shooting and these [ __ ]
people did it hats off to him alright
let's get to the let's get to the
questions here for the week God knows
there's no advertising all right from
Kuwait
dear mr. burr loving your podcasts so
who are the government's borrowing all
this rescue package money from the
bankers again they they will have even
more control for decades what do you
think I am a British teacher stuck in
Kuwait under 22 hours a day curfew in a
district that has been isolated for two
months now you and your podcasts have
kept me laughing and angry in equal
measures your wife and little girl sound
amazing makes me miss and appreciate my
family who are 4,000 miles away keep
making us laugh and go [ __ ] yourself
what is my opinion on that like a lot of
people I think this is the time to take
the [ __ ] down I don't know they just
must be paying people off because at the
end of the day they're just bankers I
mean who would you want to get into a
fistfight with a banker or somebody who
[ __ ] fights in the UFC right Oh some
tough guy in a bar those those are tough
people bankers are not tough they're
just heartless people in offices
beautiful beautiful laminated gold
offices or whatever the [ __ ] it is
they're doing yeah they're the only ones
not losing money they're just they're
they're Ray Liotta [ __ ] you pay me I'll
give you three months off but after
after after three months you owe me four
months plus the interest okay I'll give
you a 90-day break before we go right
back to the wheel and you got to run you
know faster than [ __ ] ever what is my
opinion on that they
the [ __ ] reason so many people are
suffering I add on it maybe that's
oversimplifying it just the all right
I'm gonna go rogue here it's God's fault
if you believe in God it's God's fault
okay and God has been using the devil as
a scapegoat for long enough okay just
like a great Hollywood movie the you
know you don't have a movie unless you
have a nemesis and for some reason this
guy God is the mohican create [ __ ] and
everything but he can't get rid of the
devil why does he just get rid of the
devil is he bored up there so he sort of
lets the devil [ __ ] tempt people and
all of that [ __ ] and if anything isn't
he playing with matches and when he
burns down the barn whose [ __ ] fault
is that
all right God or I will continue to
watch porn yeah it's God's fault if you
believe in God it's God's fault if not
it's just we are a defective species
that's just smart enough to [ __ ]
everything up all right old football guy
for old guy I am an old guy and I love
old football you know pre-super Bowl any
information that I can [ __ ] learn
about I'm reading this book about you
know the code and NHL hockey that's all
I'm doing is reading all these sports
books and I got to look this up I got to
try to find an old school fight from the
40s and 50s the 40s and 50s dating great
if you grabbed another guy's jersey for
leverage they immediately came in and
broke up the fight so what you did is
you actually like sort of boxed until
you were tired and then both players
would just skate away and go to the go
to the penalty box so I'm one if there's
any footage of that I gotta look that up
all right old football guy for old guy
greeting you flashback football focused
freckled [ __ ] that's not a flashback man
it happened well I guess the flashback
is you remembering something that
happened all right you're right you're
right okay well you still have some time
before the bait while you still have
some time before the baby arrives check
out Baltimore Colts great Geno Marsh
Marsh Eddie he was 11
I'm Pro Bowler and inducted into 1972
hall of fame as New York Times obituary
included the following story in the
waning moments of the 1958 championship
game against the Giants football
historians say this is the greatest game
that was ever played this is the way
this was sold to people it was a very
important game I don't think it was the
greatest game ever played I think it was
the game that put NFL football on the
map according to the NFL but it might
have been the 1951 when the Browns their
first time in the league from the Mickey
Mouse League they wanted but the NFL
didn't want to address it I don't know I
don't know enough about it but anyway he
said in the waning moments of the 19th
Philly Batory says in the waning moments
of the 1958 championship game against
the Giants in Yankee Stadium he pulled
down Frank Gifford inches from a first
down forcing the Giants to give the ball
back to the Colts for one last-ditch
drive quarterback Johnny Unitas who gets
credit for inventing the two-minute
offense even though Otto Graham they
only had a minute 40-something left
in 1950 and drove down against the
[ __ ] Los Angeles Rams to beat them
see what happens you can start arguing
even though you can't throw a ball
quarterback Johnny Unitas and the
Baltimore offense took advantage of the
opportunity driving 70 yards for a tying
field goal machete who broke his leg
making the game-saving tackle watched
Unitas United States heroics from a
stretcher on the sidelines then looked
on as running back Alan Ameche I hope
I'm saying these name rights scored
eight minutes into overtime to give the
Colts to victory in what many still
refer as the greatest game ever played
maybe because it went into overtime
where the the Cleveland Browns 1950 was
a last-second field goal kicked by home
lo the toe Groza alright prior to his
football career Marchetti also served as
a machine gunner in the Battle of the
Bulge during World War two that's when
the Germans went up through Belgium
Belgium in Belgium Belgium and
Luxembourg through this terrain that
everybody thought was a
you couldn't get through unsurpassable
or in sir passable whatever the [ __ ] how
have you said uh I got a lot stronger in
the army he said carrying the 42 pound
machine gun all over Germany helped
Jesus Christ they they just uh mate
they don't make men like this anymore
they do but they don't have an
opportunity to do that because I'm sure
they got like some I'm sure Apple makes
a machine gun now that's like really
light and super thin but that wasn't it
my shady success was not limited to the
football field while a member of the
Colts he opened a pizza and hamburger
stand with the loan from the team's
owner that's how little money they made
Carol D rose bloom that's back when guys
were named Carol Carol O'Connor Carol
Dee Rosenblum the place Gino's became a
baltimore favorite and eventually grew
to more than 450 restaurants in several
states in 1982 Marchetti sold the chain
for forty eight point six million about
a hundred thirty million today to the
Marriott corporation which converted
many of the restaurants to Roy Rogers
fast food outlets thanks for the podcast
and congrats to you and the missus oh
that's [ __ ] great dude any any more
information like this I love this stuff
you can't get enough of it alright this
is this is an interesting one everybody
and I actually thought about not reading
this because I thought this was a great
idea and I didn't want anybody to steal
it but I also want to encourage this
person to go for it this is called bible
thumper bill my name is blah blah blah
I've been a fan of yours for years I'm a
bible thumper when I've done when I've
done jail ministry basically giving a
sermon in jail the convicts will start
giving telling their story basically and
they'll use the word [ __ ] they'll
immediately follow with sorry I didn't
mean to cuss he says I work in a factory
I was a drill sergeant their language
doesn't offend me if I weren't a past if
if there weren't a pastor in the crowd I
would have replied please quit [ __ ]
apologizing we're not in church or in a
correctional facility
I know exactly what your language is
gonna sound like the moment you walk out
door when I get drunk and share Bible
stories with junkies and ex-cons I use
potty mouth do you realize how brilliant
this is so then what happened well you
know [ __ ] Jesus goes down he's like
hey you know you [ __ ] want some more
fish because I got a [ __ ] basket
right here I would go to this church the
convicts say dude if you were to do that
on video every convict in prison in this
country would watch your [ __ ]
so I've suggested that my church friends
respond with you'll bury yourself if you
do that I've watched a routine where you
talked about going to church your
theology is all [ __ ] up
you know what I'm too [ __ ] dumb to
know what the Allah what is theology
mean my my my worldview all right you
guys know what it means right you know
what it means you can look it up I'll
look it up later yeah yeah I won't your
theology is all [ __ ] up I'm sure it is
I didn't know what it is but I'm sure
you're right that's okay if you were to
push Jesus which I in no way expect
using Street vocabulary you would be
more affected than any of the forty
thousand other people pushing their [ __ ]
my position is this if you want to reach
the Chinese you have to speak Chinese no
matter what demographic you want to
reach you have to speak to them in their
native tongue if you want to reach the
dirty you have to speak dirty I was
raised by a drunken bartender he hired
me to work in a bar at age 13 I
graduated and joined the Army Infantry I
was a paratrooper
I became a drill sergeant while being a
construction worker I married a
nymphomaniac I satisfied her this guy's
talking crazy [ __ ] I love this guy I've
worked in a factory for 30 years
I would like to preach in locker room
vocabulary you would do better than me
if your theology wasn't so [ __ ] up
that's the second time now that's
personal you've quit talking about my
theology I don't know what that is but I
don't like you [ __ ] the first time
you know I'm warning shot I get it I
need to [ __ ] clean up my theology the
second time was part
he said advice oh wait a second from
Jesus Christ what do I think I think
that's a [ __ ] great idea and you
should go do it you should go do it you
should absolutely [ __ ] do it you
could change those people you know if
you have a good heart you could help
them out and I think you can make a
fuckload of money doing that because I
for one would buy that [ __ ] DVD
however you do it just [ __ ] you know
record them that's what you want to do
you record them and then you put them up
on one of these [ __ ] iTunes things
and you just tell these stories we've
all heard just was [ __ ] the way I'm
talking right now and god [ __ ] said
you shouldn't [ __ ] lay down with
another [ __ ] dude if you're also a
[ __ ] dude
okay you got to clean up some of that
[ __ ] right you got to get getting really
anti-gay [ __ ] you know throw your kid
in a bush before you say I don't love
God one of the dumb [ __ ] you put me
first let me tell me that didn't come
from the [ __ ] church is that theology
[ __ ] up huh you potty-mouth [ __ ]
good luck to you sir I say you do it
alright anger management
I built a long time listener here I love
when the lady's right when they write in
I'm writing because I've got a bit of an
Irish temper okay when when somebody
says they have a bit of an Irish temper
like that's like a great setup in a
movie if a guy's sitting in a bar what's
going on with you hey I got a bit of an
Irish temper and then you just smash cut
to them [ __ ] you know then when what
Brad Pitt did to that chick in the end
of [ __ ] that movie there might smash
your head against the fireplace trying
to keep away the ending I'm writing cuz
I've got a little bit of an Irish temper
that means she hasn't speaking to spoken
to her parents since the holidays and I
figured you'd know a little bit about
that just I just recently got engaged to
this angel of a man
now let's not take down the Irish here
I'm mostly German so most of my anger
you know you know it has German blood
running through it he's he's incredibly
patient I just recently got engaged to
this angel Oh a man he's incredibly
patient and calm opposites attract
to things I am certainly not I've dealt
with anger my entire life meditation and
exercise helped immensely and I've been
able to keep it in check in my career
however the rage is real and now that
I'm engaged I don't want the long-term
effects to ruin my marriage I'm sick of
watching [ __ ] YouTube videos on this
so please from one angry [ __ ] to
another help a girl out thanks for all
you do keep me sane I would go talk to
somebody and what's helped me is
whenever I start to raise my voice my
daughter just goes down and then I go
you're right you're right buddy you're
right and I keep telling my wife to do
that if but for some reason she won't
because it would mission wouldn't if she
imitated my daughter it would make me
laugh and would it zaps me out of
whatever it is that I'm doing and I
remember like somebody sent me something
that was saying that back in the day the
Greeks thought that anger was temporary
insanity and that really stuck with me
although I know it just it's it's like
anger my anger it's like a volcano in
that it's dormant for a while and then
it just you know like a dormant volcano
then it comes to life for a little while
and it's just like I don't know I mean
you're basically asking like an addict
who's still using how to [ __ ] stop
doing it I would definitely I would talk
to somebody who isn't angry because all
I can do is just relate to your
frustration but that's what I would do
and you know I would really work on it
and then I would talk to the person
you're gonna marry and say that I don't
want this to be an issue and but I need
help just like an addict says I need
help with this I can't do this by myself
so I've gotten to the point that when
I'm losing my temper in my head I might
bill stop doing this stop doing this but
like it's like this muscle memory and I
you know more times than not continue to
the ugly end of it but you know I was
going for walks but now I got to grab a
mask and all of this [ __ ] and I still
gets me even more many [ __ ] mouth
breathing [ __ ] cake you want to work on
the beach you know it makes me even more
upset so I don't know you're asking me
to help you solve something that I
haven't solved in my own life all right
so if you figure it out let me know but
I would definitely talk to a
professional and talk to the person that
you're with and just element that you
know just let them know the ride that
they're signing up for and that you need
help I'm sure you'll be fine all right
buying american-made products all right
we're close to a recession especially
with this virus killing people that's
that is 60 or older and some younger
people that's 60 that are 60 art and
when China shut down months ago we saw a
lot of stuff dwindle and supply I've
recently found a lot of american-made
products that we skip over because they
are more expensive than the cheap
disposable things we buy from China this
is a great thing
bedsheets cookware a few appliances home
decor and sports equipment these are
things we buy and hope to use for year
before needing replacement
so before you fast-track an Amazon item
google it and see if it is if there is
an american-made counterpart we'll be
supporting our fellow countrymen and
women I love this I love this Trump
loves this make it great again Plus
these American products usually have
killer warranties here's a link to buy
some American made and manufactured
stuff I don't own any of these companies
so don't bust my balls all right I'm
gonna retweet that it's buying American
blog.com slash made - in - USA - list
okay
there you are all right overrated people
who hate other people's success
I worked hard to achieve a life greater
than that of my friends who are all
townies and drink at the same bar oh
yeah I'm sure they're happy for you it's
at that point it's at the point where
they actually dislike me now and I have
no pity for them I'm at peace with it
now but it bothered me for years when I
saw Joe Rogan make a large deal for his
podcast oh my god that was insane
I wasn't mad that he was going to make
all that money why would you be this guy
I mean that that's one of the most
historic deals in Hollywood this is a
guy who left the Hollywood system and
everyone don't do that man everyone's
gonna forget about you completely
outside the system while sitting right
in the middle of it master of his own
domain and turn around and made that
deal like that if that doesn't inspire
you you're I don't know what does
anyways I wasn't mad that he was going
to make all that money I was happy for
him I think it's because I believe in
myself and I see how amazing things can
happen exactly people who don't believe
in themselves have to dislike it as a
defense mechanism yeah cuz it reminds
them that you know they have something
that they need to put the bed they need
to [ __ ] go after so anything or
whatever but I something you know I
don't it's it there's a number a bunch
of reasons why I mean I've been guilty
hatin on people everybody's done that
but the older you get the more mature
you get you like you like it's like me
hating on people going to the beach you
know
just cuz I would love to go down there
take my shirt off and go swimming you
anyway I wish I knew that this back then
I would have I would love to have told
some of them wait a minute people who
don't believe in themselves have to
dislike it as a defense mechanism I wish
I knew this back then because I would
love to have told some of them I guess
meaning the Townies that they are just
scared of trying things themselves and
they just want me to fail so they can
just keep being negative no they want
you to fail so it makes them feel better
about not going after what they want and
nothing will bring regret like not going
after what you want you can forgive
yourself you know that's what that's how
you get past that you forgive yourself
because you didn't know but then from
here on out you just go for [ __ ]
you know learn how to bomb [ __ ] it
she said no fall right well you know you
asked you asked her out she said no
great but for the rest of your life
you don't have to worry wonderfulest you
know you [ __ ] took the test you
failed whatever take it again do you
know you want to do this job go after IB
got it bill we know what me okay sorry
all right great other songs by bands all
that I love this okay
segment alright I kind of did that
already with the Robert Palmer album
some people can do what they like what
was the one Spanish moon I like that
song oh [ __ ] now that's my like that I
like that [ __ ] slow [ __ ] 70 dry
drum [ __ ] anyways where are we it sounds
like porno music well I watch a lot of
porn
alright Stone Temple Pilots and so I
know off of tiny music songs from the
Vatican gift shop the whole album is
amazing this track is a bit jazzy and
more indie rock than normal
Stone Temple Pilots number 2 everyone
knows living color's cult of personality
but the song middleman kicks ass I've
never I never bought their I don't know
whine up about their homes as you
imagine might imagine Bernie Reid shreds
criminally underrated guitarist yeah I
think that people were so surprised that
african-americans were playing that
style of music that they forgot to kind
of listen they were more staring I saw
will Calhoun play one time one of those
Bonzo bashes and just completely
abandoned
what Bonham played and just [ __ ] went
off and I remember at the end of the
night going you know if Bonham came back
and watched everybody doing all of his
[ __ ] he would he would be flattered that
everyone wanted to play like him but the
guy that would have really got him going
was will Calhoun cuz he just [ __ ] went
up and made the song his own which is
obviously what John was doing if I could
be so bold to speak for him which is
really a stupid thing to do but I meant
that in a respectful way alright I'm a
huge Pearl Jam fan
and it frustrates me that people only
know the same five songs that radio
shows repeat every day listen to you are
listen to you are off of the [ __ ] off of
the riot act album off of the riot act
album listen to you are you are off of
the riot act album Jesus Christ
CAPITAL LETTERS did not help me he tried
to help me I thought it was you are off
you are off of the riot act album by far
Pearl Jam at their best I would also
recommend indifference and I got ID okay
I left I don't know much about that band
Carl Douglas known pretty much only for
kung fu fighting has far better material
on the album the soul of the kung fu
fighter Oh kung fu fighting not too
racist to song check out too hot to
handle and the rest of that record for
that matter didn't scratch your bald
head with me while we wonder why he was
only known for the first song on that
record cheers love the show alright I
got one for you if I can find it if I
can find it I love the deep cut thing is
I don't know who came up with this it
was not me this is the greatest [ __ ]
thing ever all right what is that song
Dream Weaver by Gary Wright as that is
it Gary Wright if you get the Dream
Weaver album okay
I would sell to this there's one two
three four five six seven eight nine one
two three four five six seven eight nine
tracks I would put Dream Weaver maybe is
the sixth best track on that I mean this
guy he tried to make an album because
everything was so guitar-oriented he
wanted to make an album
that had no guitar so it's all keyboards
but so it's weird but the keyboards
sound like guitar
either way it's a killer album and I
forget the drummer's name on this one
[Music]
here's another one that that's called
love is alive the [ __ ] is going on my
god computer here [ __ ]
what was the fun I gotta find out the
drum on that one see I love that that
dry sound you can [ __ ] hear the drums
you can hear the ghost notes you can't
hear all that [ __ ] [ __ ] in the 80s I
just I never was into that we got it
bill you're not into it alright I'm not
into it you're not a producer either all
right Gary write drama it's some of the
most tasty [ __ ] [ __ ]
hmm come on you [ __ ] [ __ ] performers
Andy Newmark Andy Newmark [ __ ] kills
it on that album [ __ ] kills it
alright there you go
alright I gotta go I gotta go watch my
kid here by the way she [ __ ] crushed
one right over the [ __ ] wall
like Mark McGwire no steroids in the
lefty I gotta I go who's whose it was a
great left-handed power hitter Reggie
Jackson Reggie all-natural Jackson 3
home runs hit one World Series game okay
that's the podcast everybody
mouth-breathers keep going to the beach
man let us know how safe or dangerous it
is
you know if it's safe then you know what
that means mouth breathers you figured
it out and you're smarter than the CDC
alright make it great again go down to
the beach get in the water cut yourself
shaving get in the water see what
happens the co vid crisis alright
alright [ __ ] I'll talk to you later